hey I've breaking news for you somebody
on Fox News told the truth and and sort
of more relevant breaking news it wasn't
Shepard Smith it was a guy named Gerard
Baker from Fox Business and Gerard Baker
said that white supremacists undoubtedly
see Trump is being on their side now if
you live in the real world this isn't
hugely controversial I've interviewed
white supremacists white nationalists
like Richard Spencer and they've said to
me in completely certain terms that they
see Trump is their guy it's not that
they expect Trump to say down with the
Jews they don't expect Trump to say get
rid of all non-whites from the United
States although Trump is hilariously and
tragically hinted at that ideology by
saying we want Norwegian rather than
Haitian immigrants but big picture they
like Trump because they see Trump is the
closest thing to them in terms of the
atmosphere that they want which Trump
creates and sort of allows so generally
speaking obviously white supremacists
see Trump as being somewhat on their
side so Gerard Baker just says it plain
and simple on Fox and he is the Wall
Street Journal's editor-at-large no
left-wing publication to say the least
here's what he had to say that the
comment is also right there's no direct
linkage between President Trump you know
even when president even when he was
running running for president saying you
know after terrorist attack we shouldn't
ban all Muslims from coming into the
country to figure-eight he says that he
does deserve blame for the trend yes sir
I think that what does I think there's
no question that white supremacist large
numbers of white supremacists see Donald
Trump and other people like him that's
kind of on their side they don't you
know you read again you read this
manifesto this guy doesn't doesn't say
I'm doing this in the name when you
think about the guy in Pittsburgh that
shot up the synagogue he was actually
frustrated with Trump he was mad at
Trump for not doing more so for her Bush
Bush press secretary Dana Perino jumps
in trying to run interference and talk
about the synagogue shooter but Baker
gets it in there he says the white
supremacists see Trump as being on their
side
this isn't controversial we know this
the Fox News audience is now calling for
the head of Gerard Baker how dare the
narrative be questioned but it's
and undeniably true how we deal with it
and what the repercussions are of white
supremacists sort of feeling like Trump
is the closest thing to their guy that
they've had in the Oval Office recently
as an open question I think it was
Andrew Gilliam who said about his then
opponent in Florida Ron de santis
something let Don run to Santis
something like I'm not saying he's
racist but I'm saying the racist believe
he's racist we can apply that to Trump
the white nationalists don't see Trump
as a white nationalist per se but they
believe that he is generally on their
side either implicitly explicitly or by
sort of indifference and neglect to
actually doing something about them and
we can discuss the issue with Fox News
of there being a kind of limited dissent
that's allowed we talked about this
earlier today when we were talking about
Donna Brazile joining Fox News former
interim DNC chair Wow
Fox News welcoming diversity of opinion
you have to remember that this stuff is
allowed on Fox News as long as you don't
come in and question the status quo in
any serious way you don't question our
political system in any serious way you
don't question media consolidation and
and corporate media power the sort of
infrastructure that allows media
companies like Fox to become powerful in
the first place so along the same lines
Gerard Baker said something that's just
obviously true and shouldn't be
controversial it is among people on the
right but it really shouldn't be
controversial so when he says this or
when Shep Smith says Trump lied or when
Chris Wallace calls somebody from the
Trump administration out let's not hold
them up as heroes because they're still
part of the machine they could leave
anytime they're being used to provide
cover for the status quo period but I
think it's safe to say Pat that it is a
net positive when we have someone like
Gerard Baker say something like this to
the Fox News audience because we're it
not for people like Gerard Baker or Shep
Smith or whoever you might have a Fox
News audience that literally never hears
some of these counterpoints
does the fox news audience honestly
believe that white supremacists white
nationalists support democrats like
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton I mean
I don't think so I think that they
understand that they largely support
Trump but it's just one of those things
that they want to ignore and they don't
want to tune into Fox News and have
someone on the television program
telling them otherwise telling them that
that is the truth that white
supremacists like Trump it's just
something they want to block their ears
and tune out yeah the right analysis has
to be a multi-level analysis which is
that an individual appearance or an
individual instance where either a
Republican or a Democrat liberal
conservative whoever introduces some
sanity and and kind of factual basis to
the Fox News audience that's good they
still can be and I would argue in many
cases are reinforcing the status quo
that is the corporate media apparatus
with very clear lines as to what is
acceptable in terms of the debate and
what would fall outside of that and get
you completely blacklisted or banned as
we've seen happen to people on corporate
media before but as far as the facts of
what Gerard Baker said he's completely
right the white supremacists do see
Donald Trump as being their guy or the
closest thing to their guy that they've
had in the Oval Office for certainly for
their lifetimes no question about it
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blink
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you'd like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa k mas